One of the last things I did live
was a show hear at Largo.
With, like, Sandler and Apatow, and...
[Lauren] Oh wow.
And it was so much fun, and I think
a couple of days later...
everything shutdown.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
Literally the day things
were shutting down
I did Who Wants to Be a Millionaire .
I got to like be a contestant.
And it was the most
exciting day of my life,
and then we like went back home and
everything was shutdown,
we couldn't tell anyone.
It was like the weirdest
most dystopic feeling.
Has it aired?
Yeah, yeah.
Did you win anything?
I won 500,000 dollars for charity.
Charity?
Yeah.
Oh. I would love if...
Well did you wanna know the question?
That I, I actually wanted
to quiz you on this.
Uh oh.
Because, I thought you would
know the answer to this.
I may not, but go ahead.
Okay, this was the question I had to get
to get the 500,000 dollars,
and I had to call my dad
as my lifeline and he helped me.
But, Okay,
six U.S. presidents share
the same first name,
John, James,
George, William.
Which, there are six
that have that one name.
Uh, it's not William.
Can I hear em' again?
John, James, George, William.
Wow. George Washington, George Bush,
man that's a really good question.
It's really hard, and I
don't know anything about
presidents so I was like totally screwed.
Yeah I do, I just know that
there's a lot of George's,
and then there's James
Madison, James Polk,
James uhhh....
Man!
Now you're just one ago.
No, I want you to guess it.
Okay, can I write these down? George,
Yeah.
I'm eliminating William.
George, and I think I'm
wise to do that, hello?
You're correct, you're correct.
George, James, and what's the other one?
Um, George, James, John.
John Adams, John F. Kennedy...
(whispers) I'm gonna say it's not.
There's James Garfield.
There's a lot of James,
there's James Polk, there's...
(sucks teeth)
Do you wanna hint?
Yeah.
There's like a nickname associated
with one of the names that also makes....
Like there are more presidencies
use a nick name as well.
Well,
yeah cause, I think it's gonna be James.
Because... I just think it has to be James
because it can be Jimmy,
it could be James,
it could be Jim.
Yeah, so that's what I would...
Yes, that's correct.
But, it was so tense.
My dad, I called my dad and he said John,
and then we were just sitting
there for like ten seconds
and I was like, are you sure?
And then he was like, James, James, James!
And like it hung up on him,
and then I had to sit
there for ten minutes
and weigh whether or not I trust my dad.
Like, it was just like crazy.
You know what, I wish, I
wish I had been on that show.
And I wish I had answered that correctly.
I think I would have
answered that correctly,
and then,
I wish that I had won, and
I'd been really excited.
And then I wish that on
camera they had reminded me
that the money goes to charity.
(laughter)
And I wish everyone could
have seen my face fall.
(laughter)
And then me start to kinda ask like...
(stutters) yes, I imagine
some goes to charity.
And they're like, it goes to charity.
(laughter)
And then, see me getting into it with the
executive producers as
the credits come down.
(laughter)